[Music]
fans of descendants to have been
anticipating a sequel for quite some
time now
actress china anne mcclain teased us at
the end of the movie and now it seems
like she's giving us another hint what
does this mean for Emma and the rest of
the movie let's find out hit the
subscribe button to get more videos from
the things don't forget to hit that
notification spell to never miss another
video again now let's check out Emma's
transformation descendant three teaser
one of the many things we loved about
descendants 2 was getting to see the
protegees of some of our favorite Disney
villains
these include Harry the son of Captain
Hook and guilt the son of pissed on and
then of course there is umma the
daughter of the infamous sea witch
Ursula's at one point uma wanted to join
up with now in the gang but was told
that she didn't quite fit the bill as
all Disney fans know this sort of
alienation typically ends in betrayal
and this case was no exception uma makes
a powerful enemy and also provides the
audience with a powerful hint at the end
of the movie she's portrayed by actress
China and McClain who lets a secret slip
out during the ending credits she states
you didn't think this was the end of the
story did you which led many fans to
assume that we would be getting a sequel
at some point new characters and like
many other assumptions it turns out this
one was absolutely correct the plot has
been kept a secret for now but we did
get to see an official teaser
announcement based on this it seems as
if Mao's father will be playing a major
role in the next movie in addition to
all of the familiar faces we're looking
forward to seeing again well beginning
to see some new characters as well
Disney fans know that one of the most
criminally underrated Disney films of
all time is Hercules and we'll finally
get to see Hades again this time
portrayed by Cheyenne Jackson will also
see Christian comfrey and Luke Rustler
playing Smee stuns squeaky and squirmy
Jamal Sims will be played by dr. Fazli a
and his daughter will be played by Jada
Marie
among the many members of the returning
cast is of course uma the one who let us
know we could look forward to a
descendant 3 we have seen some promo
shots of McClain with cast mates Thomas
Doherty and Dylan
play fair and it seems like the
antagonists are fiercer than ever
they've also gotten more than a few
upgrades when it comes to their costumes
Harry's classic bright red has been
replaced with a darker look and he might
be overdoing it on the eyeliner just a
bit uma is still resplendent in
turquoise but her hair style has changed
from braids to mostly string
she's also ditched her signature fringed
clothing for some more practical leather
pants they say a picture is worth a
thousand words and if that's true what
does it give worth masks gifts well
that's exactly what actress china anne
mcclain teased us with via her instagram
recently she posted a gift that was both
tantalizing and confusing and added the
caption hmm
what am I getting this cast done for
you'll see soon enough clearly it's
definitely not soon enough for fans who
are aching to know what this could
possibly mean we see McClain sitting in
a chair while various people fuss over
her and seem to be prepping her face for
something but it's definitely not for a
face full of makeup it's a good thing
she isn't wearing fancy clothing because
soon they're smearing a mysterious green
goo all over her face and head it
appears to be some sort of plaster or at
least we're going to hope that's what it
is and not some type of scary new facial
mask after everything is covered except
for nostrils there's nothing for her to
do but sit there and wait it seems as if
quite some time passes before the next
step of this process begins next a
mysterious bluish purple slime is poured
all over her head covering up the green
slime almost entirely then she's covered
with what seems to be strips of gauze or
fabric as layer upon layer of them are
added by various hands this is quite the
painstaking process and definitely
doesn't look like it's even close to
being pleasant it's probably better than
constantly smelling like shrimp but not
by much if we had to guess after a while
it seems like MacLean is positively
mummified during this strange process it
took a while for all of these layers to
be added and then just as quickly
they're all removed MacLean gets her
face wiped off and other than a few bits
of green goo looks like nothing ever
happened
so what was all of that we're guessing
that they were making a cast of her head
the process looks similar to
used in mass making and there's a hidden
hint in the video if you look away from
the busy hands and increasingly obscured
face you'll see some spooky looking face
molds up on the wall in the background
see Kalia we all know that mermaids are
half-fish creatures but Sakuya are less
well known mythological creatures they
have origins in Asian and Native
American folklore and they're what we
see Ursula as during the Little Mermaid
we know that her daughter uma
can also transform into a giant Sakuya
but this raises a lot of questions what
is Emma's true form is she truly a sake'
Lea like her mother who just mimics a
human form for the most part after all
we know that Ursula certainly has no
problem taking on a human form when it
suits your needs in the Little Mermaid
it seems like we aren't going to see uma
going over to the light side anytime
soon and she may decide to follow more
closely in her mother's footsteps or her
tentacles as that case may be is umas
true for Masekela
or something else entirely maybe we'll
get to see her transform into something
else entirely in descendants three face
and head casts are often used in film
for the foundation of foam latex makeup
it could be that Emma will rely less on
her human form and discover what else
she can transform into we know that
mouth glowing green eyes signify the
growing of her powers but we might see
uma undergoing a similar physical
transformation there are so many reasons
why the production team could be making
a mask of Emma's face that it's hard to
choose just one scenario whatever the
reason is we definitely can't wait to
find out china anne mcclain has
definitely given us all a ton to
speculate about as we eagerly await
descendant 3 what do you think the new
mask will mean for umas character and
the rest of the cast let us know your
best guesses in the comments section and
then hit the subscribe button for more
from the things thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]